Cape Town is facing an unprecedented
search ecological crisis never before in
the history of the modern world as a
whole city of this kind threatened to
run out of water for its citizens
completely Cape Town residents have been
told not to use more than 50 litres of
water a day that sounds like a lot the
water you use in your short morning
shower is now literally all you have for
the entire day in terms of daily
bathroom routine if it's yellow let it
Mellow and well here is also if it's
brown it Mellow exactly and for
showering the water goes into buckets
and his use of something else hand
washing is any way out and we're now in
most bathrooms seeing hand sanitizers
Cape Town authorities are threatening to
find residents who exceed the daily
usage allows up to 10,000 ran I spoke to
a girl from Kenya and she was saying to
me I heard in your country you use fresh
water for your toilets and she started
laughing yeah we do do that that makes
no sense at all last week our water was
cut off by 11 a.m. so we've been forced
to go through the Newlands spring to get
wood last year in 2017 we had a third
year of below normal rainfall that was
unprecedented it's hard to attribute
specific events to climate change but an
increase in extreme events life draft is
what we are expecting from climate
change a lot of the blame made by
politicians is to the public saying that
their wasteful of resources it's a shame
for a city to say so what are crises
because most of us in especially and
they let townships forget a lot of
people that must fetch water 15 days
away from their houses open living in
the day zero for many years I need to
water at home desperately because my mom
actually she's on the age where she wets
herself I must wash it rice and then
home
am I gonna survive it's very much
worrying cuz we also rely on the
tourists coming in and all that how can
we provide them with good quality
hospitality and also we got like 50
liters so we can use definitely don't
use as much at the best of times we
should be saving water and we don't the
solutions that are at hand are kind of
engineering solutions desalination
plants which haven't yet been built
there is sufficient underground water in
this region to help resolve the problem
the restrictions are not really good to
restrict the agricultural community
although that could happen in future you
probably will continue to consume South
African wines but the questions will say
that the South African people be able to
consume water out of taps in this case
it is not just the problem suffering
it's also the rich who are suffering
will have to change their behavior so
maybe you could consider this a note
from your future what's happening in
Cape Town now might soon happen to all
of us in relationship to water to energy
to air we need to start solving these
problems we need to manage our resources
more rationally and collectively because
otherwise it'll be Daisy row for these
central resources
[Music]